last but not least we have discussed
europe but we do not forget
the rest of the world the pandemic is
global
in a couple of months in europe we will
have more doses
than we can use with biontech and
moderna authorized
we can vaccinate up to 85 percent of the
eu
population these are 380 million people
at the same time other parts of the
world the poorer ones
see themselves as left behind in the in
the access of covet 19 vaccines
from the start we have invested in covax
the global vaccine procurement facility
covax remains the best route for
universal vaccine
solidarity but as there is a global rush
to vaccines there is thus a shortage
i have suggested an eu mechanism to
share
access to some of our vaccines
until kovacs is able to deliver
poor countries with large quantities of
vaccines
vaccines that we agreed to share as part
of
team europe could be channeled through
covax
we can and we should do this without
disrupting ongoing national vaccination
plans
and in coordination with the companies